KLAY THOMPSON, 20 POINTS.
FIVE REBOUNDS, AND A SHOOT
AROUND WITH WILL FERRELL.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE GAME --
>> JACKIE MOON --
>> HOW ARE YOU ABLE TO FOCUS
AFTER AN INTENSE WORK OUT WITH
JACKIE MOON?
>> WE HAVE BEEN IN A TOUGH SPOT
WITH -- THE Ls HAVE BEEN
STACKING UP SO I WAS GRATEFUL
TOLL SEE JACKIE.
I JUST REMEMBER THROUGH MY
REHAB, I WATCHED "SEMIPRO," THAT
KEPT ME IN THE GREAT LIGHT.
LOOK AT HIM.
HE CAN PLAY.
>> THE WAY HE CLOSED OUT ON YOU,
HE HAD TO BE NERVOUS.
>> I DIDN'T WANT TO COME OUT OF
MY FEET.
THEY WERE DIRTY.
DON'T WANT IT TOO MUCH.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE YOU LOSE FIVE IN A ROW, IS
IT A FACE THAT DRAYMOND'S NOT
HERE?
MY SHOT'S NOT FALLING YET?
WHAT IS IT?
HOW DO YOU LOSE FIVE GAMES IN A
ROW?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I MEAN, WE TOOK A COUPLE BAD Ls
PRIOR TO THE ALL-STARE BREAK.
AND TWO GUARD, ME, COULDN'T MAKE
A SHOT FOR A WHILE, AND ON TOP
OF THAT, WE HAD INCONSISTENT
LINEUPS.
BUT TO BE HONEST, SHAQ, I DON'T
HAVE A GOOD ANSWER FOR YOU.
BUT HOPEFULLY WE CAN WIN FIVE IN
A ROW HERE.
BOUNCE BACK TIME.
IT'S A LONG SEASON.
KLAY.
>> IT'S GOOD SEE YOU BACK OUT
HERE, MAN.
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN TO FIVE
MINUTES, WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR OUT OF THIS TEAM TO LET YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE WHAT IT TAKES TO
GET TO THE SIX SPOT?
>> THANKS, DWANE.
THAT MEANS A LOT.
FIRST, WE HAVE TO GET HEALTHY.
DRAYMOND, HE'S THE HEART OF THE
TEAM, ANDRE, OUR BIGMAN WISEMAN.
ONCE WE SEE THE TEAM AS A WHOLE
THAT WILL BE A LOT OF FINE.
DRAYMOND, I MISS HIM OUT THERE
ON THE COURT.
SAME WITH ANDRE.
AND COME PLAYOFF TIME, NOT EVEN
THEN, THE LAST 16 GAMES, WE GOT
TO JUST CREATE GREAT HABITS
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PLAYOFFS, IT'S POSSESSION BATTLE
AND WE CAN'T HAVE EMPTY
POSSESSIONS.
WE HAVE TO GET A SHOT, AND GREAT
BALL MOVIEMENT.
I'M REALLY EXCITED FOR THE
FUTURE AND THIS IS GOING TO BE A
GREAT YEAR.
I CAN JUST FEEL IT.
>> KLAY, I ECHO WITH YOU, IT'S
AMAZING TO SEE YOU BACK OUT ON
THE COURT.
THE THING I HAVE BEEN IMPRESSED
WITH.
AND THE MENTALITY, BEING ABLE TO
STEP UP.
>> YOU HAVE A CLUTCH GENE, AND
YOU HIT IT ON A RUN YOU ARE
STRUGGLING A BIT GOING IN THE
POST SEASON, AND HAVING THAT
EXPERIENCE.
>> Stan: YEAH, I MEAN, IF I'M
GOING TO SHY AWAY FROM THE
MOMENT, YOU KNOW, WHAT AM I OUT
HERE FOR?
THAT GOES FOR ANYBODY.
YOU KNOW, BEEN THROUGH TOO MUCH
AS A TEAM, IN MY CAREER, TO BE
AFRAID OF THE BIG STAGE.
SO I'M EXCITED JUST TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY NIGHTLY
AGAIN, IT'S SOMETHING I DON'T
TAKE FOR GRANTED AND IT'S A
PROCESS.
I HAVE TO FIND MY LEGS.
I HAVE TO FIND MY WIND AND I
KNOW BEING OFF AS LONG AS I WAS,
I CAN'T JUST JUMP BACK INTO IT
AND BE THE PLAYER I WANT TO BE.
I KNOW THAT'S GOING TO TAKE A
LOT OF TIME AND DISCIPLINE AND A
LOT OF HEART.
BECAUSE THIS -- IT'S NOT JUST
GOING TO COME EASY.
I HAVE TO PLAY WITHIN THE
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE A DEEP TEAM.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT ROTATIONS.
BUT AS FAR AS -- YOU KNOW, THE
KILLER MIND SET, I MEAN, IT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT YOU REALLY
CAN'T TEACH, AND I THINK THAT A
LOT OF GUYS ON THE SQUAD
OBVIOUSLY THAT HAVE.